Kaitlynn has had a wild ride a lot of
its her own doing but it's been a wild
ride The Bachelorette airs its season
finale Monday and Chris Harrison
addresses the rumors about Kaitlyn's
choice with ET saying yes she might not
pick anyone kayla is probably one of the
more fearless bachelorettes we've ever
had if ever there was a possibility of
her just walking away with nobody it's
it's this season just because she's
having such a tough time and she's
dealing with these two guys that are
kind of making more drama than there
needs to be it's getting to the point
where it's not even about Kaitlyn
anymore it's about each other and how
much they dislike each other as for the
next Bachelor
a decision has not been made you know
contrary to popular belief yes we have
frontrunners and yes of course the bins
are frontrunner but both bin Z and Ben H
would be great bachelors but you know
what so would Jared so would cupcake and
so we really have an embarrassment of
riches to deal with and you know we have
to see what happens with Nick and Shawn
et spoke to Harrison on the set of Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire he'll be the
hit shows new host this fall